It's a rain, sẽ không có kế hoa xong phạm chủ quyền cắt đámu đận đữa trong tượng lai hủy
ông cũng tăng thành đe sống của tổng thủ Trump về câu chế bà bên
mình đi xerêng cắt đa, giám dài quyết nhận bất đồng còn tổ đồng
về phần mình thủ tưởng cắt đa, anh thả niên lên an mạnh mẽ phủ không gích
giảnh mạnh như vụ bảo vệ công dân cắt đa là UTN Tên đối
đồng thời đại khẳng định quyết tâm bảo vệ chủ quyền và bàn vệ lạnh thủ nữa nhá
ông át thân ni cùng nhìn mạnh, đô hà sẽ tiếp tục lạng chung dân hoa ra để chống dưới cuộc chiến ở giải gà ra
Chậu đỏ vong emu chiến ở chiến, Isharaen đã thực hiện vụ không kích nhằm vào nhóm lạnh nhận
hà mắt đa của mắt tạo thủ đô đô hà khiến nhiều thành viên phong chào này và một nhân viên anh em cắt ta thiệt mạc
cắt ta gọi vụ tấn công là hành động khu bụ nhận nước vì phạm được của tế và chủ quyết bú ra